okay
help your
midst
uh
a
sorry we had a couple technical difficulties
and I'm very E.P., and Touma has the giggles.
I don't know. The indie record's got to be with that one. If she don't talk to her, I don't talk to her.
That's pretty good, actually.
That's really good.
I might steal that. I might make that a stream title at some point.
That's funny.
That's a really good one.
Oh my gosh, I didn't. We got to have a little scuff.
Just a little bit.
It adds the flavor. It's like seasoning.
Just a little bit of zinnacea.
I feel like I hear Reina jumping somewhere, and I feel like she's going to start singing the song of her people very soon.
We do love it. We do love when they sing the songs of her.
Yup, I think she was an opera singer in a previous life.
Have you ever considered taking her to a pet psychic?
Oh, bless you.
Sorry. What?
Have you ever considered taking her to a pet psychic?
That would be so funny.
She was maybe one of the George Washington cats or something?
Oh my gosh. I'm going to do that. Take my cat to a psychic and tell me about her.
I actually, at my last job, I had a customer who was just like,
I'm like, oh, because I try to make conversations so I can make recommendations for products.
And I was like, oh, what do you do for work?
And she's like, oh, I'm a medium.
I'm like, like the size?
And she's like, no, I'm a spirit medium.
I'm like, oh, OK, that's cool.
And I'm like, the fact that you can do that for your job is pretty cool.
I said that in my head, not allowed.
And I was like, when you said I'm a medium, my first instant like thought was,
I don't know, you look like a small to me.
Yeah, like I was literally in my head.
I was just like, like the size clothes.
Like, I guess that might be like a little bit, you know, valid, but like,
but, you know, and she's, I'm like, oh, that's neat.
How long you've been doing that for?
She's like very long time, like 20 years.
I help connect people's passed away pets to their loved ones.
And I'm like, no way.
What?
And she's like, yeah, here's my website.
And she pulled up this entire website and it was like really well made.
And I'm just like, wow.
And she's like, you've had someone who's passed away.
And I'm just like, yeah, she's like, don't worry, she's all right.
And I'm like, what the?
What are you talking about?
Let me just jumped up and bonked his head on the microphone.
It's so funny that that happened to you.
Like I had a very similar experience except I was on a plane and the guy was looking
over at me and he's like, all right, tell me about your spiritual journey.
And I'm like, huh?
That's so wild to me.
Just like people just like dial in.
They're just like, hmm.
Yeah.
So tell me about this time when you were.
It's like there's a little bit of psychology to it almost.
Tell me this time when you were a kid and the trauma and the person and this and the
people in your spiritual team.
And you're just like, I don't know.
I don't know.
Hello, everybody.
Hello.
That's our free, our opening app is about the interesting people we run into that are
psychic mediums.
They're cold open.
And if you're new here, hello, because I see some new faces.
My name is Sheeby Cottonbomb.
I'm your favorite girl failure, dumb bunny girl of Gen 1's indulge vealer.
And I like to do fun, wacky voices and dress up my characters.
And then this is Trinket.
Hello.
I'm Trinket.
I'm your favorite step dog or your dog in law.
It just depends on how you feel about me at the time.
And you'll find me on Tom McCuse's channel on Twitch.
But you know, I'm a visitor to the YouTube sphere.
Yeah.
She comes over every once in a while.
Hello, Raiders.
Oh, it's a Scotland raid.
Hello, Scotland.
I hope you guys had a very nice stream.
You know, you know that real, you know what surprised me that I'm 25% from Scotland.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
Trinket Scottish.
Just like me.
I'm also 25% or something like that.
I'm a bit of a mutt, but like I already knew that.
I know I barked like Goddard from Jimmy Neutron there for a second.
He's a full quarter guys.
I think I'm actually like 20%.
Actually, I'm not, I'm not 25.
So, Toma Trinket is more Scottish than I am.
Let me tell you.
Sorry.
It's raw attitude.
That's what it is.
It's raw.
It's all, all the attitude came from the Scottish portion of the pie.
But Trani, I hope you had a good stream.
Make sure you get some rest or, you know, knowing her.
I feel like sometimes she raids me and then just starts another stream like an hour later.
Cause she's like, she's just on that grind, you know.
But make sure you rest, Momay.
Thank you very much.
And I hope you guys, if you guys want to stick around, feel free.
Or you can go like hang out whenever.
Yeah, have some water.
Have a snack.
Take a nap.
Don't take a nap.
Treat yourself.
Take a walk.
Put us in your ears.
Take us with you.
We're good for a laugh.
We're good for...
I think you can physically put us in your ears.
Like shrink me down.
We could misfrizzle it up in their brains.
Yeah.
Okay.
So we can crawl into your ears and we can just whisper sweet nothings to you.
That would be a good ASMR actually.
Yeah.
It's like, okay, put me in the strength device.
Okay.
Now shrink me.
I'm going in.
She doesn't remember.
Stream in five minutes.
Okay.
That makes sense.
But for you, for you, for those that's sticking around, thank you for coming.
We have had this little mini series.
Oh, did you Pokemon smash or pass?
We are currently on the 200s.
But did you want, did you want to chat a little more?
I loved chat.
Yeah, me too.
You know, I'm a serial yapper.
That's true.
We would be here for like five hours between the both of us.
It's true.
I guess.
Sorry.
I keep interrupting.
I'm so terrible.
No, no.
It's because Discord has the bit of a delay.
So we'll both start and then we'll both stop.
That's a good point.
I was, I also am terrible with pot.
I can't tell when people pause proper.
Like, when do I talk?
Well, I have the same thing because like, I, I know my dramatic pauses can be pregnant,
but like, I don't know if anyone else has like pregnant pauses like me.
Um, I was telling Azura, because Azura was telling me that she pauses for a while too
to think, and I'm the type of, so it's funny because like when I talk to Azura, um, she
will talk and then pause because she's thinking, and then I go to talk because I don't want
to forget my thought.
And she's just like, wow, it's definitely ADHD for you.
And I'm like, I just want to make sure I don't forget.
Well, I mean, I mean both ADHD, but like different.
Different.
Different flavors.
The worst type is the type that makes you forget.
That happens a lot because I was like, you, you were talking earlier and I'm like, what
was I even talking about?
I was talking about Twitch versus YouTube and why it's good for us as a company to be
on YouTube.
And I'm like talking and then I just, I was tweeting at the same time that I was live
and then I just totally forgot what I was talking about.
And then Trink had to remind me.
Well, that's okay.
Do you ever like just window shop and like you're thinking, oh, I should look that up,
but you're continuously looking at the thing that you were looking at and then you forget
the thing that you were about to look up.
And so you have to like do the little song and dance of, okay, what was I thinking about?
I was thinking about this arbitrary thing.
Okay, that's what I wanted to look up.
And it comes like 30 minutes later.
Yes.
The worst.
Alternatively, I managed to look it up, but then I go down a rabbit hole of looking up
stuff because like, I remember I was like looking up an actor from a TV show because I was watching
Vikings and I'm like, I swear I've seen this person before.
And then I fell in this rabbit hole of all their like filmography.
And then I was going through other films that were just in the same genre.
And then I woke up and the TV show was like half over through the episode and I'm like,
okay.
Well, I have to go back and re-watch this now.
Oh, I hate when that happens or when you're watching anime and you kind of check out when
the stuff is going.
You're like, oh my God, I don't know what the plot's going on about now.
You just like totally like disassociate your eyes cross and you're just like watching,
but you're not reading.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
I actually fell down a rabbit hole maybe like a few months ago about when I was looking
at plushies, right?
Because like I have a need to be underneath a bunch of plush toys.
Oh, very nice.
You know.
Very comforting.
It is.
It's so comforting and they're so comfortable and like it just weighs on you like a bunch
of puppies, but they're still alive.
Dead puppies.
I'm sorry.
Dead puppies, the opposite of dead babies.
But like the rabbit hole was, did you know that there's just like a genre of plushies
where you just have mama animals just giving birth to like little baby animals?
What?
Yeah.
It's like they're the big mama cat and then she has like a zipper and then like a bunch
of babies come out of her.
Wait, I actually have seen stuff like that.
You could pull like all these like little kitten thingies and there's like many versions.
I've seen, I have seen that version.
I thought you meant like.
It's not like the for real pets though.
Oh, it's like newborn.
Oh, it's weird.
Wait.
Now I'm curious and I want to.
So I'd be a leg.
Okay.
Let me grab.
I've seen like the newborn like alive stuff.
Oh, and there's different types too because it's not just like puppies.
Like I'll give you the snake one too.
There's a snake one.
Yeah.
In fact, I'll link that one first.
I would like the snake one.
I like snakes.
So here's the snake one.
And then like the pictures are really funny to look at.
Oh, here's a bunny one for you.
You know, nothing.
Nothing too.
What the?
Oh, they're so cute.
And it's like a zipper egg.
Yes.
Okay.
I might be adding this to my, to my throne because this is kind of adorable.
And then like if you get down like the egg rabbit hole on Etsy, like you'll find that
there are silicone eggs to like, you know, experience.
Oh, yeah.
Alien, alien giving.
Interesting.
Fascinating.
And again, you're a bunny.
So like you already know about that with Easter and stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
Of course.
It's like I was, I was raised on that knowledge.
Everybody knows eggs come from bunnies for Easter.
Yeah.
So like you don't need to know about obby position or nothing like that.
No, no, that's, that's, that's old news.
That's old news.
Trying to fix my shirt.
Pardon.
Yeah.
I'll tell you what is new.
Face huggers for Easter.
Yeah.
When are we going to incorporate face huggers?
Aliens are the new bunny in my mind.
Well, you know what, you're not wrong about that.
I'm assuming you've seen the new Romulus trailer, right?
I have not seen the new Romulus trailer.
I have popcorn bucket.
No, no, there's a scene with a face hugger that I know you would love.
Oh my God.
I'm going to find it for you right now.
I'm not going to lie.
Face huggers are a special interest for some of us.
Oh no.
You are good.
Yeah.
You're going to love it.
I mean.
I mean, it's not a Pokemon, but like Smash.
Hold on.
I'm making sure this is the right trailer.
I'm excited.
Also, I'm a little scared.
As you should.
Every action of a spooky movie trailer.
Well, actually, it won't be the full thing.
It's going to be one scene from that trailer.
Maybe it's cut down on Twitter because I can't find it on there.
Well, yeah, because that's where all the freaks are on Twitter.
I saw it like posted like a bunch of times.
And then I'm like, wow, Twitter is indeed a bunch of freaks.
Come on.
You got this.
I believe in you.
If I just look up face hugger.
Well, maybe that could work.
I don't know.
Well, maybe people are making a lot of cool.
There's a face hugger 3D phone holder.
That looks pretty sick.
I'm not going to lie to you.
So like, so like, we all know that the hose underneath it is it's like a thing, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Because like, when I was a child, I didn't understand that.
I didn't either.
But now I understand it as an adult.
And I'm very, I'm very grateful for the wisdom that I have.
Did they clean off this clip?
Where is it?
Oh, no.
I literally.
You know what?
Hollywood is full of a bunch of cowards.
Where did they go?
I literally just looked it up on the tick talk.
It was the and it didn't.
It was going to bother me.
I'm determined now.
Okay.
But you could, you could move on to the next, the next topic.
I will continue to search.
Let me think the next topic, huh?
Oh, shit.
I just had a topic too.
And I've forgotten it.
Well, that's okay.
Wait, I might have it.
We, we think we found it.
You know what?
Hollywood is a bunch of cowards.
That's what I was talking about.
There we go.
Because like, okay.
So Hollywood always does this thing where they try to make you think that
something is sexy when you clearly know that it's not supposed to be.
Yeah, they definitely did that.
Like one of the things that the nineties in the early 2000s would try to
make you think is sexy is bees.
What?
It's like the weirdest bee propagate I've ever seen.
Cause like, oh, ween bees.
Oh, there's a bee and she looks kind of human.
The bee movie.
I found it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Not safe for words.
Oh.
That's a, right?
Isn't that crazy?
Oh, that's a, that's a clip, right?
Right?
I was like, I remember watching the trailer and I'm like, I had a visceral
reaction.
I was on, I was, I was, I didn't know what to think.
Can you see?
Google it yourself.
Oh, hi, Mercy.
Mercy will believe in the bee propaganda.
No.
All right.
You, you don't, you don't have the eyes for Barry, for Barry Benson.
Do you?
Oh.
The bee.
But yeah, he's so seductive to the human race.
How could you ignore such a voluptuous bee?
I mean, with such, with such riveting conversation starters as,
you like jazz.
But like,
he's kind of a stud.
You know what?
Like, bee movie makes me think a lot.
Like Patrick Warburne's character.
I feel like he was justified in being really hurt.
Oh.
I'm actually getting blown off by your girlfriend for a bee.
You think they actually did anything?
Like her and, her and Barry?
I 100% believe so.
Also, how come we never see the queen of Barry's high?
That's a great point.
You never see the queen.
You only see the, the, like the, the flyers, the drones.
And then that's, and then like there's a mayor.
Yeah.
Or something.
She's too hot for TV.
She probably is honestly.
Probably.
Or maybe they, they didn't want to push a bee propaganda, but they did for like
male bees and not female bees.
Yeah.
Maybe they just did like a little like control group and being like, we're like, okay,
which do you find more attractive?
And they showed, uh, they showed, uh, what's a Barry Benson?
And then they showed the queen bee and then they were just like, sorry, Barry.
Like he's just, he just oozes more, uh, sensual stuff.
But do you want to see a Holly would be that like lives in my head or in free that I think
about from time to time?
Show me.
Oh, I'm such a nun.
By the way, I'm very, I'm very holy today.
Queen bee.
Oh, that's where is that from?
That's from two stupid dog show.
Oh, I've never seen that was on boomerang.
Well, I mean, it was on Cartoon Network first, but yeah, I guess you could say it was on
boomerang.
You see very offended.
I said boomerang.
I'm not, I'm not, I'm not offended.
I'm not offended.
Speak your truth.
Talk about boomerang.
What's, go off sis.
I know you want to.
Okay.
So this, this particular episode, right?
It's not so much that she's all, she's a queen bee who's like super sexy, right?
It also has like her force feeding secrets, girl, her royal honey jelly and hypnotizing
him to be in love with her.
I might have to watch this episode.
Yeah.
And she was basically going to make him her little love slave.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, pretty much.
Who is behind the writing of the show?
It was episode.
I mean, I, it's literally on the picture I sent you.
Oh, you're right.
I'm staring at it.
I'm literally staring at it as I say it.
Mark.
Sarah.
Sarah Cheney, you, Sanny, whatever, you are something else, sir.
You need to praise the Lord and look inwards and self reflect.
But like, but you know, hypnosis wasn't really mainstream, a big thing.
Well, actually, no, it was very mainstream hypnosis was like go to plot point in the
90s and the early 2000s.
We've only recently started like stepping away from like just hypnosis in general.
Interesting.
Because I realized it works on people.
Oh yeah.
No, it's because probably this is a conspiracy theory.
We talked about mind control so much that the government was like maybe mind control
work and now we don't talk about mind control so much.
Because never met using mind control so much.
I might have to agree with that statement.
But like, you didn't hear it from me.
I'm just a silly little dog.
Yeah, I'm just a silly bunny talking to this little dog.
And you know, I never know.
Yeah, she's a nun and I'm a belly dancer.
We're just two peas in a pod.
Two peas in a pod.
Maybe.
They're not if they're watching, you know, I have the Lord and Jesus and anime on my
side, so I'll be fine.
Okay, should we start the.
We should we should we should actually start.
This is gonna be a very holy stream 100%.
It's why I'm dressed like this.
Everyone got their Bibles.
Everyone Bibles out.
I was going to start with the scripture.
So I hope you guys enjoy.
Scripture 200 of smash smash.
Viticus smash.
Written by prophet poke I'm on.
I'm misdreavus look like a little booty butt head.
Honestly, you could make her look like a used napkin.
If you if you just like, like.
You went zero to 100 so fast.
Was I supposed to?
No, you're fine.
I'm just my my innocence was shattered in that one sentence.
You can make her look like a used napkin use tissue if you want to.
I mean, I mean, like she's already got a pearly necklace.
All you need to do is add your own.
Trinket got jokes today.
Oh my God.
I can't even I can't I was going to be like I'll steal her pearl necklace.
You could do that too.
But you could replace it.
I can't breathe.
I'm sorry.
I'll pull back a little bit.
No, no, no.
It's a it's a very this is a very good cop bad cop.
Light versus darkness.
I'm a nun.
You're a belly dancer.
You're the devil on the shoulder.
I'm the angel.
I like it.
I kind of want to eat it for some reason.
I don't know.
Yeah, it looks like a little gummy candy.
Yeah, like I take a chunk out of it.
Yeah, I'm assuming you'd smash though, correct?
Yes, I'm building the smash.
All right.
I would pass but eat.
If I was a male, then I would totally understand smashing this.
This is a letter.
This is a drawing.
This is a sketch.
This is the eye that you sketch in your notebook in high school when you're bored.
I mean, I guess I could get hooked on phonics.
I don't want to pass.
I don't I don't want you could use the appendages though, but he just be staring the whole time.
I mean, he can watch ever watching like the Lord.
Yeah, it's fine.
Like it's like exhibitionism, but like a solo audience.
It's like it's completely just glaring at you no matter what.
I'm gonna.
I'm passing.
I'm smashing.
What?
No way.
I'm surprised.
Well, I mean, it's no different than a toy.
It's just alive.
That's true.
I didn't want the reminder was left.
If I'm just using it as a tool depends.
Um, maybe it's just like cool with it.
Yeah, probably.
Whoa, buffet.
Wow.
Okay.
But like, what was that got knocked back because if you hit wabba fat, it bounces back at you.
Like twice as hard.
So that's something to consider.
I don't know if I could take that.
I mean, I'm saying smash because I like wabba fat.
I would say pass because he's got a goofy face and I would probably just laugh too hard and I get distracted and couldn't finish my scripture.
I mean, you're not trying hard enough.
If you can't finish your scripture.
Maybe, okay, maybe I'll sit in the chair for that one.
I'll learn your ways.
I'll have to like see it for myself.
I'll pray to high heaven for you.
Thank you.
Smash your.
Hallelujah.
Yeah.
Is this some sort of Bible study?
Yeah, it is.
Yeah.
This is a Bible study.
It's a very unique Bible study.
Yeah.
If you want to just open your website to smash viticus 202.
We're on wabba fat.
And first wabba fat.
First wabba fat, yep.
And the Lord said wabba.
And the Lord said, as this person said, gonna wabba on this.
Why are you mocking religion?
I am not.
I am being say so.
Yeah.
I'm trying to behave.
She is, I'm trying to change her from her terrible ways.
Trying to show her the Lord's light.
Are you trying to make me repent for my wicked ways?
Yeah.
Making you repent from your wickedly ways.
I don't know.
I'm trying to earn a scarlet letter here.
And that letter is an A.
You are well on your way.
Trying to turn into less of a furry?
Yes.
All the furries must be cleansed.
I don't think she'll be able to convert me.
I don't think so.
She's pretty stern in her beliefs.
Very, very solid.
It might be very difficult.
I'm a furry.
I would like evidence your honor.
Scroll down real quick.
Scroll down.
What are you?
You don't mind?
We can improve it right here.
I'm leaving.
I'm walking away.
I'm out of here.
Goodbye.
Oh my God.
I'm out of here.
Well, exhibit A, as you can see.
We have so many choices here that prove the madam may or may not be a furry.
Your honor, I was coerced.
I know I'm really good at public speaking and selling, but that's a straight up Gyarados.
I see at least two cats are marked.
There's a turtle, two snakes, two.
You got a few of them.
I'm being corrupted.
Anyways, I'm passing.
Yeah, the unicorns too, huh?
Garafrig.
Well, I don't got to tell you nothing, but two heads are better than one.
Oh my God.
This looks like a really cute.
I wouldn't want to pet this in a petting zoo and just not make eye contact with the tail.
That's rude.
I will have to.
I'll have to pet.
Well, not like a pet.
Wait, did you say?
What did she say?
That's rude.
Why is it rude?
You can't.
This will put my little petting zoo.
Yeah, but the tail deserves attention too.
Oh, okay.
You got that cute little face.
You can say no to that cute little face.
It reminds me a lot.
I don't know.
I don't think I've seen her.
I've seen her.
And there's attention to an.
Okay.
Cute little face.
I think no to that cute little face.
It reminds me a lot of like do you remember soul eater?
Did you ever watch soul eater?
Yeah, I did watch the leader.
I love Maka.
Do you remember like Krona and like.
What the heck is it's little.
And it's a little freak the guy who disrespected.
a time, poor baby. That's what this reminds me of. Or Venom. It's just Pokemon Venom.
You know what? I could see Chrona being remade in Pokemon as a Molly or a Mawile.
Yeah. Oh, actually, very, very good. I would 100% agree with that.
Maka was like my favorite though. I liked Maka and I enjoyed Soul Leader up until like the last
three episodes. Because like the manga wasn't finished when it was being like ran. So they
had the bullshit and ending and it was like ugh. Yeah, I love the bowl. Yeah. But then you read
like the canon ending and the manga and you're like ugh. Dang. Wait, I have a question. Yeah.
It's popping to my head. Because Squishy said which is the back. But then
how does it eat and where does it expel from when it's done?
Well, I mean, it's probably got regular genitals. So like the giraffe head is like the front part
that eats. But like the tail probably has like a carnivoreistic uh carnivoreistic sort of situation
going on where it'll eat like any sort of prey that's behind it like a bird. Yeah, I feel like
I would like buy that thing so I'd like get too close and like consume them. Yeah. It's like catdog.
Yeah, I don't even want to like catdog always bothered me for that reason. Yeah, because like
in catdog the situation was the genitals were like located under the armpit.
What? Is that canon? Yeah, it is. It is canon. I didn't even know that.
Yeah, because like whenever dog needed to go he would have always left one of his leg.
Oh my gosh, you're right. And then cat would do the same and they always had like the litter box
and the hydrant sort of situation. Oh my, why did I never put that together that well obviously if
it's going from there if it's pee pee in from there it's gonna poo poo from there too. They
got some stinky armpits then. Yeah, they do. Imagine like having that right in next to your face.
I mean,
else are into that. But I always like catdog. I thought it was a funny. Oh no, I love catdog. I
was just yeah, I was always confused because I would ask my mom like how do they use the bathroom
though? My mom's like it's just a cartoon. I'm like okay.
Is it either packing too? Well yeah, of course.
But what are you feeling for this one smash or pass? I'm gonna say pass because it gives me a mental
headache. Smash. Okay. Which side would you pick?
The underside. What are you asking?
Like say you're going in for a smooch.
I'm not kissing that. Well, you'll take that but you're not gonna.
No, why would I kiss a horse?
Oh my god, a pinecone.
I know pinecones you can make into food and there's like seeds and stuff you can eat.
I know I'm an obligated like omnivore but I'm not eating that.
Yeah, I feel like it would be like too crunchy to be like eating like bark. So I'm gonna say
it knows explosion and hardened. Yeah, but it looks like too sharp. Like look at the top part.
I can't use that. That's too many ridges.
During a bible study, that'd be terrible.
All right, lay it on me. Come on.
I wouldn't smash his pine nuts.
You're such a dark.
But I wish I had that as like a thing I could pull out.
Oh brother, this dog sticks.
No, that's not fair. It's hot out.
No.
Ow, I just got like a pain in my jaw after drinking my lemonade. What the heck?
I think that was karma. Yeah, get her karma. Get her.
Okay, flared. Well, like you could use it. You could use the pointy part as like
where you pull it out. If you turn it upside down, I guess it could be like a masochistic plug.
Yeah, like ribbed for no one's pleasure though. Yeah, I feel like that would just cause like
internal bleeding. And then I kind of feel bad because his eyes would be all up in there,
but just be dark. I feel like his eyes would like let be cast upon by cheeks.
Oh, that's like like lightly peeking out. Yeah, just lightly peeking out because like
it's it kind of flares like right underneath where the eyes are.
Yeah, you're good. That's a good point. So yeah, I guess it would just be peeking out.
Yeah, fill in O. You know, I'm all for self flagellation and in the name of the Lord,
I'm going to smash the pine cone. Understandable. Have a good one.
I've been convinced.
Oh, Boomi came up in this grooming Fia. I have Fia on my desk right now.
She even and Boomi is giving her a kiss. I was she kind of got like messy when I was feeding her.
So I'm kind of glad that Boomi is cleaning her face. Oh, he's probably just going in for the
extra food. Literally, that's why I'm like, that's fine. You can't sit on her though, Boomi.
So she's laying in my bed. Um, for Tret, I honestly, I don't like the name of this one
because it doesn't look like a fortress. Like I know it's very like locked down.
But yeah, it's not on it. Should it be like a forest?
How I don't understand how you would do this one. It's like,
like one, maybe like super 10 point accurate, like rosebud sort of suction toy. Maybe. Yeah.
But then that's so boring. This one's boring. Maybe you could use it as a double ended.
Boomi, you just sat on Fia's face. Maybe. Did you guys hear her squeak?
He just sat on her face. Are you okay? Yeah, that's what I was thinking, Kevin. I was thinking
like a party for like you and three friends. Yeah, that's why I was like a double ended sort of thing.
Kind of like kind of like the multi pussy for like a bunch of guys.
Have you ever seen that? Yeah, I've seen that. It's like a like a whole like thick disc.
Yeah. And like multiple guys can get in on it. Somebody said that there should be one for
Vila of all of us and then you can just like switch it around when you want to.
And I remember is different.
Um, I'm gonna say no because I feel like I would accidentally push air up something.
Yeah. And I would just and I would say queef and I would just queef. Yeah. Oh, it's my baby.
Baby Don Spas. I love baby Don Spas. He's the most useless Pokemon. I kind of want to eat him. He looks
like butter. He looks like butter. Yeah. But he also looks like he'd be a pretty cool looking plug.
He would be pretty cool looking plug. Yeah. Look at his tail. I feel like either end.
Honestly, like he could get up in there. Honestly, I just want to cuddle him. He's too cute for me.
He like I just want to eat him. I'm going to say pass but eat because he looks like butter.
I'm passing it and I'm cuddling. He's he looks like gummy. I want or like a gummy bear. I'm going to
I mean, I mean, you wouldn't be hurting nothing. Ain't no thoughts behind them eyes.
That's true. He's just hanging out. Gligar. Gligar. I can't talk.
Gligar. Yeah. What's that? What's that? What's that tongue do?
I like his little scorpion tail. I've always liked gligars. Yeah. I always thought he was like
a better version of a Zubat. Yeah. He's got little pointy toes. Yeah.
Little tail. You could probably use that as like beads, tongue, little handles.
He's got poison though, right? He's got poison though. Yeah, but he could maybe he can control it.
I don't know. You risk that paralysis if you want. Well, I either way, I want the tongue.
Oh yeah, the tongue definitely. And then I can use the horns as handlebars.
Or and you can also use the little snippy snips as nipple clamp. Oh, of course.
He's just utilizing friendly. Yeah. Utilitarian.
I'm going to say smash. Me too. Nope. This is a pass. Felix is a pass.
Why? Come on. Give him a chance. You give him a chance. No, I'm good. I don't like
Stelix like that. Or Stelix mega looks cool to look at would probably kill me.
Yeah, I guess I can't see. It would hurt. Not in a good way. I'd probably just perish.
Yeah. Oh, snubble. I've always liked snubble. Again, a lot of Pokmon were ruined for me
with the live action movie. Snubble was one of those. Oh, I thought snubble was cute in the live
action. It was too like hyper realistic for me. I think I think Pikachu was the only like cute one
for me. Well, that's because he's the title character. Yeah, good point. Um, they had to do
I'm going to pass on snubble though. She looks like a bratty little child. I just want to take
her by her little ear ponytails and just throw her around like Matilda.
You know, I think I'll also pass only because like there's a better one coming.
Yeah. Yeah, pass. Granbull.
Yeah, I'm good. I don't like it. I like it. I'm a smash.
All right. It's a little bit better. It loses the dress and it gets some skin.
That's a good point. Is it wearing like some sort of bandana or is it a collar?
I think it's a collar. Okay. No grand pussy. No grand pussy. No. Thank you.
The teeths. What I don't want anything to do with those teeths.
I don't know. They're kind of cool.
Okay. What about a quill fish? Eating it.
And getting it prepared by a fancy chef who knows how to handle puffer fish because they are poisonous.
Do you think quill fish are like poisoned in the same way that a puffer fish is?
I feel like their liver would or whatever it is that's poisonous. I think it's the liver. Yes.
I would have thought it was like the swim bladder. That's a thing fish have, right? Yeah.
I don't remember. I haven't watched like a puffer fish preparation video in a while.
I usually like to watch one every month. I'm not even joking with you.
I just like to watch people do catch and cook videos.
I got so sad when that really cute one surfaced. You know the one where it's like,
wow. It's like eating the carrot. Oh yeah. And it was like biting some. That was a wow.
And then like at the very end, like they just kind of slap it a little bit and then they
wipe its mouth and then they're just carrying it away and you see him pick up the knife.
I first saw that video and I was like, no. Wait, I didn't even know they killed it afterwards.
I don't remember. Oh gosh. That's so sad. At least it doesn't have to like live with the
embarrassment of having that done to you. No. Oh my gosh. So like a couple of months ago,
I was watching TikToks, right? And there was a guy, there was a guy who caught a fish, right?
And he slapped the fish a few times after he took his hook out. He spit in the fish's mouth.
I saw that. I'm like, what did that fish do to you? Why are we sexually harassing fish that we
catch? Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. What about the history version? No, that's a no for me. But it does look
cool. Scissors look cool. Yes. Smash. Smash. Just like Scyther. I don't know why. I don't know what it
is. He just looks good. Yeah. Cut that body, otty, otty. Oh. The mega version. Smash. But like,
I don't know because those look scarier than the other claws. That's okay. You don't have to worry
about those other claws. All you got to worry about is like the plate on the front. All right,
I'll smash you. Do you think it like descends and like whatever's on the inside just sort of like
that? It just like, like it falls open like it's like a ship, like a spaceship door opening.
Or maybe it like heads and then it like regrows after the deed is done. Oh my god. Or maybe you
can pop it off. Maybe it's just armor. He's like, let me undress and then it's just like and then
then the boogersies is there.
Shuckle. How do we feel about this bug? I want to eat it. It does look like it's kind of tasty.
Yeah, I feel like I could fry it up like a clam. I don't know. It also kind of seems smashable.
But yeah, it does. Like I don't know why I feel like I get like a tentacle vibe from it.
Yeah. And if I was a dude, all those holes. Yeah, very holy. This is one for the girls,
like for you and your besties. Yeah. All right. Are we tag team in the Shuckle?
Yeah, we're tag team in the Shuckle. All right. Smash tag team the Shuckle. Hell yeah.
Options are definitely. Shibi, what haven't you eaten today? I literally just got food before
I got home and I ate it in like five seconds and I had a cookie afterwards. But like I'm still hungry
because it wasn't a lot of food. It was a small sandwich and I have some lemonade.
And I really just want seafood right now, I think.
You know, I think I could go for like a burgy. Like a what? A burgy. Ooh, a burgy.
A little burger poo. And a little flinty flies. Ooh, a little flinty fly. What do you feel
love french fries? They steal my french fries. That's really crazy. Uh,
hair cross. Uh, smash. Smash. Yeah, I've always liked his face. You know, I'm gonna give him a chance
because I feel like I don't know. I also just kind of want to ride him. Not like, not like that. I'm
like, I'm like, you can ride him like just, just, just like one leg on each side of the long horn
and then get the antenna. Yeah. Like he takes off and so and you blast off and everybody's just
having a good time. Yeah. I'm squashing that bug. Um, oh, what about this one though? I don't know why
it has like a vent opening in the front there. Maybe because it gets too hot. I'm very confused by that.
Maybe, maybe the, maybe the power doesn't come from like the groin area. Maybe all the
pleasure is like up in the face. I feel like you could use it as a grinder if you're like brave.
I feel like it'd be the situation of a mandolin.
I think I, I like this one's face though more than the other one. I like how he's like,
it's okay. I like the other one's face, but this one's okay. I don't think I would smash though. I'm
gonna pass. Uh, nah, I'm gonna pass as well. Up. Sneezel. Smash. Smash because she's serving.
She do serve. She just, she's just cute. She's like a little sassy little bratty.
She like do something. She could be like, you know,
yeah. Same with the history version. Look, oh, look, oh, look, oh, mesugaki, she looks.
Are you talking to me? Oh, I didn't, I didn't think so. Yeah, like literally, she's so smug.
I like it. She's so smug. Like, oh, are those your shoes? They're ugly. Trash.
Trash. She needs correcting. Yes. Uh, Teddy Ursa. Baby. Oh, pass. Baby. That's a baby. That's a
snuggle. Pass and snuggle. Hug. Hug and snuggle. Yeah. Oh, Ursa ring.
I'm trying to think of a pun with its name and I can't.
Ursa ring around my rosy. Take a pocket full of my posy. Ursa ring of my belly. Yeah, that was better.
Oh, smash. Ursa ring a ling. Ding, ding.
Oh, I think my headphones be dying. Hold on. Oh, no, you gotta plug them suckers in.
I don't even know where my charger went. What the heck? I unplugged it so I could use my camera
and now I don't know where the plug went. Oh my god, no. The fairies took it. Oh, there she go.
She's chasing fairies. Literally. I literally left it on the floor. What the? What the heck?
I see it. I said a hey. Ha. A hey. A hey. Sorry. Sorry.
Mental. Mental. Mental stim. I haven't heard that song in like forever. Same, actually.
You know where I first heard that song from? Well, it was like on a Dollar Tree CD that had a tomato
on it and it had like a whole bunch of songs and I never understood like why I found this.
Dollar Tree used to sell CDs. Now they sell DVDs. Chalk this up to Boomi having stole it.
Oh, I found it. I don't remember it going there, but okay. And it was tied up nicely. I think I'm
just forgetful. You did it. Yes. You did this. No, it was the fairies. It was those little house
hobgoblins. Oh, you've got those too? Yeah, what do they call them? Just hops? Common hop? Brownies?
Brownies, yeah. Sorry. Don't apologize to Boomi. Don't apologize to Boomi. He know what he did.
Boomi just, you guys literally just heard Boomi sit on Fia's head when she's resting after being
in the emergency room today again for the second time this week and he just sat on her and crushed
and she went back because he's big and he suffocated her. Boomi's not innocent. He's a menace. Fia,
I will stand up for you or fight for you. Because I really like goldfish. I love goldfish.
I'm trying to think of another snack I can have. Crackers. I don't have any crackers.
I think. Do you have cookies? No.
I kind of wish I had more of that cake that I made, but I had to throw some of it away.
Yeah, I wonder why. I wonder why nobody knows. Don't know why it happened, but it did. Oh,
Boomi hopped in a box. He's so cute now. All right, he's back to being a good boy. I think I have like
chips, but I'm not sure. I don't know. I'm too lazy to cut up. All right, continuing on.
It's a slugma. Slugma ball. I want to eat it.
It looks spicy. Yeah. I'm just passing. I was playing Alan Ring yesterday and there's like
these magma bosses that literally look like this in volcano manner and they're like little lava slugs,
and I also want to eat them. So I'm going to be fair and say I want to eat. It is lava. I don't
care. I'm eating it. It's forbidden spicy honey. Yeah, literally. Look at that. It's like it's
literally just hot honey. It's hot honey. That's how I'm going to say it. Like I literally want to
eat molten glass. It's so pretty and it looks so delicious. Oh, yes. So delicious. Do you see that
video of the people like pouring molten glass into like normal already regular glasses and they
explode? Yes. Oh, so good. So good. I remember, do you see the video? Do you sometimes get like
the video of the jars and full of stuff that roll down the stairs and break? Yes.
Do you get the British lady that reacts to that? Yes. She's so funny. Oh my god. She's like, oh,
that's a good one. Oh, that was terrible. No, I didn't like that one. I like her with the hydraulic
presses. Yeah, she's good with the hydraulic presses. She's very relatable. Is that the French
one? I think that's actually the French lady that I'm thinking of. Well, there's an English lady
that does it. I know the French lady. I know the French lady that you're talking about.
Although, can I ask you something? Yeah. What is up with like, you ever see those like
dharma like dramas like, oh, the racism, oh, the elderlyism, oh, the non-professionalism,
like it's always like a made up scenario that. Oh, yeah, the Darman stuff. Yeah, it's like maybe you
shouldn't judge books by their cover or whatever. Right, right, right. But like,
like lately, though, they've, they're, they're just people sitting in the corner of them
just watching and I'm like, huh? Oh my gosh. What's happening? I noticed that too. Like,
I got a recommended thing like that in my YouTube shorts and I was confused because I'm like,
why am I watching someone react to something like they're like sitting in their desk?
Like, it wasn't even like a face cam react. It was like, just in the corner, they're like full
on full body, like they're in a podcast and they recorded it live. And I'm like, I was really confused.
Like, I don't, I don't think there's a market for react Andy on short TikTok skits.
No. If there is, I wish there wasn't.
No. Uh, my cargo.
Mag cargo. My cargo. Like, my, my cargo. Michelangelo.
I, it's a pass for me, but I do want to play like with the Dooley dops, like on the side of his face.
Just be like, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop. Knock him, knock him back and forth.
He looks like he got good swing. He looks like a character from turbo.
He does look like a character from turbo. I feel like you could play with his, like,
with his little face troops too, like balls, like stress balls.
I'm going to eat them. I'm going to eat him again. He is a snail. Actually, I don't think I've ever
had like as cargo and like a snail before. I wonder what they taste like. I don't know. I've never
tried that. I wonder if I would like it. Whenever I think, every time I think as cargo, I think
fly me yet satisfying. Because like I like oysters and stuff. So maybe I would like it.
Maybe. I'm eating this sleepy thing.
That's why now. It looks like a perfect sized ham.
I mean, you're not, you're not wrong, but this is a baby. It also looks like that demon slayer
character in Osuke. It does look like an Osuke. Wait until you see the evolved form.
I'm eating it. I'm not. Pillows slime. There he is. There's an Osuke. Yeah. I always pronounce
Japanese names wrong. I'm so sorry. I like its floppy ears and that is like a little mammoth.
I don't think I eat this though. I'd eat it. It's bigger. It's bigger. More meat on the bones.
I don't know. Floppy ears to like put me off. I just want to pet it. You can do bow.
Eat it and pet it. Yeah, we eat cows all the time, but we also cuddle them too. Oh no, you're right.
Okay, I guess I'll eat it too. I've been convinced.
Two, two, two. Chancey of the sea. Chancey of the sea. Corsola.
She's just really cute. Yeah, like I kind of want to just either want to eat or hang out with her.
And I like I would maybe try to use a little pointy nubs, but I feel like
they'd just be too like the fork. Just wouldn't be attractive. The fork and bits.
No, honestly, that's a rock.
Smash. Someone said smash. It's coral.
It's coral.
Coral. Sorry.
I want to say it's like rock candy. That's what I mean. It looks like a hard candy.
Like you could definitely get some nibbles off of the nubs. Yeah, a little gobstopper moment.
I'm going to pass.
Yeah, I'm going to pass too because I can't see the grind.
Why are these both the same? Oh, I didn't mean to smash that one.
I didn't mean to smash the ghost. Bring me back.
I would notice why are they both two, two, two? That's weird. Do the other ones do that too?
I think for the glare and kind, yeah. Okay.
No, let me pass. Okay, thank you. I'm like, I don't want to. I don't want to do anything to the ghost coral.
It does look chronically depressed because all the coral reefs are disappearing. That's why.
Protect our reefs. Again, I love seafood. Eat.
Uh, I don't, but it's a fish and I ain't smashing so pass.
I like how it's reminiscent to the remora, which like hangs out by whales and sharks
and like hangs out and like sucks on them, you know? Yes.
A little, a little co, a little co-partner. Yeah.
Yeah. Octillery smash. That's literally just a rose in tentacle form. And then tentacles. How big is octillery?
Big. Perfect.
Like, like the mouth is probably like the size of the lady anatomy.
Yeah. So I can just like, just take it all in. You know what? I'm going to add a BGM. I realize I didn't have one.
You guys didn't tell her that she didn't have a BGM. You're just hearing us like our, our silences every once in a while.
There we go. A little subtle, a little subtle BGM.
62 pounds. It's two feet 11. Oh, okay. Uh, deli bird.
Smash. Smash explain.
All right. I just really like the way he looks. I like his vibe. I mean, I know he's a bird.
But it just seems like he's got clothes and like he can pull anything out of that sack.
That's true. Oh, that's why I was going to rob him.
He probably comes with his own toys. Should I do a smash and grab?
Yeah. Smash and grab.
Because like, he's still, he's still like a criminal of the highest crime.
He's just, he's just a little guy committing crimes.
He, he's, he looks like Seattle. So he's got to be, he's got to be smashed and grabbed. There's nothing.
There's no, there's no other way to put it. He's just got to be smashed and grabbed.
What is deli bird supposed to be? I know obviously like a bird. They kind of look penguin-y to me.
Yeah, it's a penguin. Oh, okay. Oh, that's why it has a sack. But why is, oh, is it deli like
delight or something? I don't even know. Where does the name come from?
Probably some weird bird. Yeah. Oh, like a new deli penguin.
Like a new deli penguin. That's probably. Oh, delivery. Like a mailman. Oh, delivery bird. It delivers presents.
Oh, man time. I don't know what I could do. I would just hang out with it. It's just cool.
I would just like when I lay on its back and fly around like coldly Yoko.
I was literally about to start singing the song and he got be me to it.
I got you homie. Okay, I'm passing on man team. Maybe I'll rewatch coldly Yoko.
Oh, that would be fun. Yeah. Did I tell you that I had a brain stint the other day where I was just
thinking of cute little girlfriend names to call periods. Like if you're a vampire.
Give me one. Vampire buffet. Vampire buffet. I like to say little ketchup packet.
Little blood bag. Yeah, little little gusher or fruit gusher.
Mm hmm. Blood moon. I know people like say that like, oh, aunt flow is coming.
Yep. It is the other Red Sea. It's a vampire magnet. Vampire magnet. Maybe start calling it vampire week.
Or the Cullens are coming. Oh, man, that's not the only thing.
Crimson tide. I've also, I don't know if you've ever watched Salt Burn.
Okay, so I'm afraid to watch Salt Burn. How was that?
It was good because yeah, I think, did you like briefly stop by during the member stream for that?
I forget. I didn't. Okay, you're fine. I'm fine. But yeah, no, it was great.
There's, then there was indeed a sin, green serenade. It was lovely. It's a great, I love
that movie. That's why I watched it twice. I'll watch it again. I just like watching other people
watch it and being like, what? I love sharing movies with people so that they can experience.
There's a movie on YouTube that was made by a guy. It's like over 12 years old and I just show it to
random people sometimes. So I can get a fresh reaction for it. It's called Theven.
Say it again? Theven. Why is it so familiar sounding?
I don't think I've ever shown. No, I want you to show me. Well, we can do that another time.
Now I want to react with you to whatever that is. If it's
you as friendly or you just do that off stream. Oh, yeah, no, it's only 29 minutes.
Perfect. I'll give you the link so you can see what I'm talking about.
Like, oh my God.
Your giggles. What is this? It's season. Oh my God. It's it's one of my
Tila Khanathan Studios. Oh, it's made by an Indian company. No, it's made by one person.
Oh, okay. One dude, then impressive. I'm just gonna.
This just reminds me of the globgulab.
Is this really the same person? It's the same art style. No, they use the same engine.
They used blender. Oh my God. It's so sometimes like unpolished blender
3D stuff is so terrifying looking. But he's gotten better. It's like clay. Like this was
this was his first movie. He's gotten better. And it truly is an experience. I'm watching this guy
run up to a house all goofy. And it's got subtitles, but it doesn't have voice acting.
Whoa. Wait, why is this woman bald?
Oh, you skipped to the end. No, I didn't. I literally skipped two minutes in. Oh, then you're good.
She's offering him tea. Okay, I'm getting distracted.
Oh, am I sharing this on stream? I am. You are.
Oh, no, I'm gonna get claimed. I'll have to cut that out.
Oh, it's fine. It's not a big deal.
Wait, you didn't? You didn't like share any audio? Well, even so, YouTube has the AI that
watches your stuff and will claim it. I did a watch along of Twilight for people who don't
know. And I pixelated the crap out of it. And it was still managed to get claimed. And I didn't do
any audio or anything. It was a heavily pixelated. It looks like that one shade of blue that you see
when you watch the Twilight movies. And this still has identified. So they have a crazy AI for that.
Oh, they're training it too well. They're training it on hentai.
If you can uncensored this hentai video, then you're good enough to demonetize content.
Honestly, I believe that.
If I can tell what's going on after this pixelation, then you're hired. Otherwise,
get out of my office. And the AI just slumped back to its little AI dorm room. And he's like,
Beep, beep, I'll never be able to uncover what this hentai means. Beep, beep, beep. Beep, boop.
Wow. If you ever, if you ever get like an AI chatbot, I'm gonna train it so it says that.
How you doing today, training an AI chatbot? Beep, boop, beep. I'm okay. Beep, boop.
Skarmory. Back to this. Yeah, back to this. Beep, boop. Beep, boop. It probably would slice me in half.
Beep, boop. I think I'd pass, but like, you could probably get some good meat if you got underneath
like the metal. True. Beep, boop. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Gonna pass. Yeah, fast. Beep, boop.
Uh, hound door.
Well, I know what my answer is. I, I'm gonna pass.
I, well, it's a very stylish dog, you see. He's, he's got his own, like, he's got his own bone
bangles and he is very stylish. I've always liked rottweiler's and how they look.
Are you gonna smash the hound door? You know, he's a puppy, so I think I'll just say pass on this one.
See, again, how doom, however. Yeah, now that's a die.
The limbs are a little, the limbs are a little longer. He's got double the bangles, double the
style. He's got his own handlebars for, you know, ease, a spay tail for spanking.
He's got a home. That's a, that's a, that's a utility knife houndoon dog right there.
Yeah, like, he goes really well. He goes really well with none cosplay. Yeah, he matches me really
well. It's like a, I'm gonna, I'm gonna smash. Yeah, smash on houndoom, you know.
Smashing houndoom. Smashing houndoom. Oh, see, see, Satan comes to town only, only twice a day.
That's more than some people, right? That's a lot of pointy things though. Can he take that off?
I mean, no, but like, it's, like, look, it's, it's not towards the back, so he's more utility friendly.
Okay. Yeah, I'll smash the mega version.
How do you feel about Kingdra?
It has a goofy face. I don't like it. It's like a really long nose and not a mouth.
Yeah, I, it's not horsey, so it's a passport. Yeah.
Aw, baby! They just remind me of the adventure time character.
Tree trunks? Yeah, may she rest in peace, the VA.
Yeah. I'm gonna say pass. Yeah, definitely pass.
Are you about to do a tree trunks impression? I was gonna try. Try it.
Wait, I need a tree trunks clue. I don't, I don't have a proctonate knowledge enough.
Yeah, she did pass away. I love tree trunks though. She was so goofy.
She was like, this is such a silly character. I remember seeing a clip of like who she was
based off of, which was like this one like woman and she's just like singing R&B, but she's like
this like really older, um, elderly white woman and she's just singing, slightly rapping at this
like black dude who's like stalking around her. She's like seducing him and it was really funny.
And that's who she was based off of.
Yeah, respectful pass on panfy.
Respectful, but don't fan. However, that is going to crush me.
I mean, you get, you get like a gate for him. The rest is like front legs on and you're
yeah, I just feel like it's like, I don't know.
He's just got the vibe of a leather daddy, you know, that's a good point.
Hmm. Like, like he's a real sleek and sexy looking design. If you asked me,
I'd probably use the top as a grinder.
Maybe just like right on top and be like, but he can also lay on his back.
That's a good point. But again, think of the, the size.
Although we are anime girls, so we should be fine.
Also, if he's on his back and you're on the top, then you can control the speed of which you go.
Yeah. And the depth, which would be out my mouth probably.
Yeah, like all the way through the thing, right?
Yeah. Then right back out. Follow, follow through.
You know what? I think I've been convinced. I'll, I'll smash the Don Fun.
I'll smash. Well, you guys could already tell. Ah, yeah, the smooth Porygon, better Porygon.
I'm going to eat it. It's a jelly bean.
I'm going to smash it. It's smooth.
How? It's circular. It's smooth. It's, it's, it's anatomy friendly.
Yeah. But what do you, where do you put it? What part do you put?
So like the tail can go in and so can the beak.
Like the tail can go in. The beak can go in. You can, you can sit behind the head.
It's got, it's got utility. How, how big is the Porygon too?
Probably not that big. Because I'm thinking of like rubber duck size.
But I bet it's bigger. Yeah, it's probably bigger.
Okay. I might watch just to learn, but I'll pass for now.
Fair. It's two foot 72 pounds. Jesus.
See, that's, that's, that's toy size.
Ooh. That's a good point. I get it.
Uh, Stantler. Pass. Pass.
I really hate its tail. I really hate its face.
Like we already had a cute year Pokemon. Why do you have to make this abominate?
Yeah. If it, if it, honestly, if they fix the face and the tail,
I would have a great time, you know? Yeah, it doesn't look like a tail.
It looks like a giant booty cheek.
It does. Let's lopside it. Passing on Stantler.
Smeargle. Smeargle.
I feel like he'd be good. Yeah. For like foreplay.
Yeah. Like you could do body painting, body writing.
He could tickle you.
Yeah. He, he probably drawn your nipples.
Yeah. I think it would be a very intimate session.
Yeah. And his little tongue.
Yeah. And he's a cute little guy.
Yeah. You know, I'll give the short king a chance.
Yeah. How could you see?
I wish it showed like their information.
Hey. Because I'm kind of, I'm kind of wondering that.
Oh, I did pass. No.
Perfect. Okay. I've never been with that.
We've never been for it back.
Irma. I kind of want to kick this sassy child.
It does look like a sassy child.
Like, I feel like he's going to pull my pants down.
And not like in a good way.
Yeah. Like, I'm good.
Yeah. No. I don't, I don't want a sassy child.
Same with Hitman. They just like another sassy child.
Yeah. Like these, they look like bully sassy children too.
Yeah. They're just, they're just rude.
Snot knows kids that just like smack you and like make an
embarrassment of their mother in public and she's trying to like
calm them down, but they're just like eating each other.
And it's like really awkward.
Yep. They roam, they roam in a gang of three, their third members,
like the next one after Hitman top.
Yeah.
With the BGL, BJLs.
She got them, she's very, uh,
a lollipop coated, but like not in a good way.
Like, like Tanya of the evil, but more like less duck, duck lip.
Yeah. Duck lips.
Because like, I could see the gang.
Like it's, it's Smoochum.
It's Hitmon Lee.
It's Tyrone, Tyrone, Tyrone, Tyrone.
I'm just going to tell them Tyrone is Tyrone, Hitmon top and Smoochum
and all in a, all in a short gang.
And like she's the boss and they're like her two like goons.
Wait, is this just like the sassy evil version of the backyard he gets?
Is it Shaniqua?
Hitman top is Pablo.
And then Tyrone is Tyrone.
They just come up on you and they're dancing.
It's like, run me your pockets.
Give us your fucking wallet.
Okay, pass on Smoochum.
Oh, and this kid's their rival across the street.
Like he's a little do-getter and he's like pretending to be a little hero.
He's the, he's the kangaroo one.
I forget his name.
Oscar.
Yeah.
It's, I thought Oscar was like a cat or like some sort of like dog, like a jackal.
I thought he was a kangaroo.
Google in this.
I don't know.
Oscar backyard against.
Cause he's unique.
Oh, it's a unique one.
Not Shaniqua.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm thinking of Austin.
Did you say Oscar or Austin?
Oh, yeah, it's Austin, my bad.
Okay, he is a purple kangaroo.
He's a kangaroo?
Yeah.
He does look like a cat, actually.
I have always thought him to be a cat and I'm just like,
yeah, he does look like a cat face, but then he has like a weird, like a, like a thickums tail.
Yeah.
Like I just thought he was a weird looking cat, like, uh, like some sort of weird African cat.
You know, it's really funny to me because
I realize how unique the animal choices are for this show.
Cause you have a hippo, a moose, a penguin, a bug, and a kangaroo.
Not like a cat, a dog, a mouse or something.
Wait, unique was a bug?
I thought she was an alien.
Is she?
I don't even know.
Let me look.
Is unique?
Cool.
Wait.
She's a unique creature.
Oh yeah, she's a unique creature and yeah, and also alien it says.
Yeah.
Oh, that's cool.
It was a self insert from the creator.
Oh, that's cute.
I like that.
That's funny.
So I'm just like looking at lore for you, Niqua.
Yeah, because it's interesting, right?
Like unique was the protagonist of the backyard against.
I wouldn't say she's the protagonist.
Well, she's definitely one of, yeah, it's like mostly, uh, her and Pablo, in my opinion.
Oh, here's an interesting one.
She is the only character who appeared in every episode.
Oh, so I guess maybe she is the main character.
Yeah, but sometimes like she doesn't have like a main role.
She's like, yeah, she's just a supporting.
Yeah.
I also thought she was a ladybug.
That's interesting.
Ma, ma, there's a weird cat outside.
It looks like grandma the fucking thing.
All right.
I'm gonna say pass on Ella kid.
Yeah, I don't want to get, I don't want to get into gang trouble between these two.
I know.
I don't want to like start no, no tour for.
Yeah.
And then this is the goofy friend that gets locked like caught up in their shenanigans.
He's like, guys, I don't think we should be doing this.
They're like, shut up, Magby.
Why don't you go home to your mother, baby?
He's like, but guys, I was just shut up, Magby.
He like tries to be the voice of reason, but he's like the friend.
That's like, he's like the little sidekick.
Yeah, yeah.
But he's like always right.
Yeah.
I guess, I guess, I know it's going to be a bad idea guys.
He's the butters of the crew.
Better not tell Magby.
Magby snitches get snitches, Magby.
Pass.
I love Mil-Tank.
Mil-Tank.
I'm sucking on them.
Utters.
Although black toast and tolerant, it doesn't matter.
Same, but like, she's cute.
She cute.
Delicious.
Smash.
Lissy, I'm eating her and her child.
I'm smashing her and her child.
Wait.
No.
Trick it.
It just says this video has been removed from YouTube.
Like, you can smash an egg, you know?
And crack it and just like, you know, fry it up.
Yeah.
Although, you could pop the egg in.
If you wanted to.
Experience the joy of obby position yourself.
Yeah.
Smash.
Okay, I'm passing.
I'm smashing.
Raiku.
Raiku, I have a special, I have a soft spot for it in my heart
because they were the first legendary I caught.
I, I respect you and I mean this as respectfully as possible.
Fuck Raiku.
I know, I know he looks a little odd, but I am gonna smash Raiku.
That's perfectly fair.
Just like we're childhood friends.
Turn to lovers, trope, you know?
Understandable.
Now, believe me when I say this for the next one.
Okay.
I'm buckling up.
Smash for daddy, Entei, because Pokemon the movie three really does something to you
when you see it at the wrong informing time of your life.
I'll smash Entei.
They look like, it looks like a very wise old man that would teach me things.
Oh yeah, he teach you things.
All right.
Yeah, exactly.
Teach me a thing or two.
You can, you can teach an old dog new tricks, you know?
You know?
Let an old dog can teach you new tricks.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wiggles eyebrows.
Quicker training.
You know a lot about that, huh, Missy?
Actually, I failed, I failed out of obedience training.
Oh no.
Sweet Kune.
Sweet Kune has a special place in my heart because Pokemon Crystal.
Are you going to smash Sweet Kune?
No, I respect her too much.
Oh, well, I'm smashing Sweet Kune.
The only, the only one I would smash is Entei.
Um, Lavatar.
Boo!
I hate him.
I hate the child.
Boo!
The sassy child pass.
Pupitar.
I mean, you know, I was thinking about it.
You thinking about it?
Because I'm thinking about like, you know, the very beginning.
What was that one Pokemon's name?
That's the Chrysalis.
I'm like literally blanking right now.
Silk, silk skin.
No.
Metapod, thank you.
I'm like, I'm waiting for Chats to catch up and figure it out.
Um, a lot of spiky bits though, like I don't see a good entry point.
Honestly, it's a pass for me.
Pupitar, I'm just gonna cancel the pass guys.
I don't know, it's a little too extreme for a bad dragon, don't you think?
Yeah, I feel like the Pine Co is a little bit different.
This is just like sharp.
Yeah.
I'm a pass.
Tyrannotar.
Now, if you have like Godzilla finish, this is the guy you.
Yup, we're smashing Tyrannotar.
Murr smashing Tyrannotar.
Hell yeah.
Not the mega though, because I don't really like what's going on there.
That just looks weird.
He looks like he's evolved into like a castle that I could just walk through.
Like his legs look like little windows.
Oh yeah.
Finding the fire is like, ah yes, time to go home to my beautiful Tyrannotar.
He looks like a tree that just like grew very oddly and then it's
branches fell off and got hit with some sort of blight.
Pass.
I don't like that.
Lugia.
Smash.
Smack my cheeks.
Did you ever, did you like Pokemon 2000?
I never really, I'll be honest, I never really watched any of the Pokemon TV show or the movies.
I've only played the games.
Really?
Yeah.
I played my games in secret because growing up I was told that Pokemon was demonic because
they're based on spirits and shinto religion.
It's like pocket monsters, pocket demons.
I remember sitting in church and they did a whole thing on that and then I stole this
kid's fire red just so I could play Pokemon because I really wanted to play it.
Man.
What?
Man, I also have religious trauma.
But like I was fortunate enough for not to be a part of the Pokemon band but I was a part of the,
you can't watch Hercules because that has other gods in it.
Yep, same.
Yep, that too.
But then like you had other kids in your church who all who got to see it and you're just super
mad and resentful and like why the fuck did they get to watch it and not me?
Facts.
I'm not a poser.
I never said I was a huge Pokemon fan, people.
I don't know what gave you that idea.
I've just played a couple of the games that I love.
They're really nice.
I love them but I don't know too much.
But yeah, Lugia is a smash.
Yep.
I like Lugia.
Ho-oh is a ho-ho and can be gone.
I know.
I remember getting ho-oh in HeartGold and I was like, I don't like this thing.
And I wish that I had gotten a soul silver.
Uh, Celebi.
That's an onion.
I'm, that's why I was gonna say I'm gonna chop up this onion, put it in a stew,
use the green parts as garnish.
Yep.
Do you think like after you cook down Celebi and you like eat it,
it's like magic lemonade rules where it still grants your wish once you've eaten it?
I feel like it.
I feel like if you like sip it, yeah, you like something happens
because you're just condensing all that power into food so you could like
store parts of Celebi for later to grant your wishes.
Yeah, like Celebi jerky.
Yeah.
Like you need a miracle.
You're like, oh, I mean like pop into the fridge, have a piece of Celebi jerky, and there you go.
Your wishes come true.
Yeah, yeah.
Pass.
Trico, pass.
Grovile.
I like the smug expression, but I don't know.
I mean.
He looks like he smokes weed.
He does look, he looks like he, yeah, he does look like he smokes weed actually.
He also looks like a bit of a bully, like he would shove you into a locker.
Yeah, like he was like the bully stoner.
Yeah.
Like, hey, you want to smoke some pot?
You're like, no.
Wow, you, you narc, are you going to tell him me then just like slams you into a locker?
Yeah, I'm a pass.
Can I get like five bucks?
He says to you in that sort of rasp.
Cool thing.
He has a dime bag.
Don't use it all in one place.
And you're like, I didn't ask for this.
You're like, I just wanted to help with like, if you knew what the math homework was that he's like,
oh, uh, later and then just like leaves and he actually gives you like a bag of oregano or something.
Yeah.
Oh man, reptile looks like he's grown up.
He went to college and dropped out.
Like the little under eye, like the red eyeliner, it looks again, like he's a stoner.
He started, he like tried to do his own dispensary, but it like fell through.
Like, oh my God, dude, I haven't seen you since high school.
How you been?
And he has like preconceived notions that you guys are friends,
but you're just remembered, like how much they bullied you.
Sorry.
Honestly, I feel like he'd be like, hey, can I like crash on your couch?
We were besties in high school after all.
Remember that one time I like gave you a dime bag for five dollars?
It was like, that was what I could know.
Yeah, but I guess you season some pretty good fucking pasta with it.
You're like, I turned it into a win so I guess you could stay over.
Enemies to lovers, Wattpad right there.
All right, I'm passing on reptile though.
I'm smashing because like we've written this fantasy though and I'm just like,
you're like, I can fix him.
I can help.
My my reptile boyfriend keeps smoking pot.
Greeting out.
Babe, stop, stop smoking pot and get a job, please.
Stop saying you're going to grow a new thing.
It's a new strain.
Babe, I'm telling you, once my streaming career takes off, you won't have to work anymore.
He's just playing like
Team Fortress only or like Counter Strike.
Oh my god.
Oh, the mega version.
This is where this is where it turns into like Avril Lavigne's.
He was a boy.
She was a girl that he like he becomes the rock star.
Like this is when he becomes successful.
And he leaves you behind and he's also a Christmas tree.
Oh, so like Skippy.
Yeah.
Damn, I can fix him.
I'm passing again.
I can't get all the freaking Christmas tree.
This is a that's a chicken nugget.
That's a chicken nugget.
Well, because it is that's a one by chicken.
Yeah, I've I've eaten that.
Like it's it's probably already cooked.
You just got to kill it.
You kill it and then just like cooks itself to perfection as it dies.
Yeah.
What hug?
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I'm overeating this.
Uh, come buskin.
Busket down.
Busket down Satyana.
Um, I'm going to make that chicken wings like those chicken thighs.
They're mine.
This is turning into a it's a bucket of chicken.
Yeah, that's a KFC bucket right there.
I'm in a KFC in like five years.
I don't think it's a KFC nearby.
Oh, man.
Pass by eating.
Yeah.
Pass by eat.
Okay.
But however.
Yeah.
A blaze blaze a can blaze a can can blaze my can.
That's all I'm going to say.
I mean, they're not even they're not even trying to hide that.
He's got a big dick energy.
I know right there.
It's right there.
And you know, like a little bit of that like the fuzzy moment,
like I kind of it's it's very real.
Like he's just like, I don't shave.
And you're like, oh, okay.
I'm into that.
Can I like braid your hair?
You like part as a hair feathers.
I don't even know.
It's probably feathers.
You just like part the feathers and that's like a cloaca.
Well, yeah.
But like once you get past the cloaca, like they're sure to be
like a thing that kind of goes or I guess that but we can we can scissor.
Yeah.
And then like once once you find out that it's a boy,
the insertion happens like like the face hugger deal.
Oh my god.
All right.
Smash the mega version.
The mega version is hot.
Yeah.
Again, same same thing.
He's like he's like a he's like the skinnier version.
He's like the skinny.
You know how like the skinny dudes, you know, surprise you, they pack a wallop.
Oh, he's packing something.
He's packing heat.
The real question.
Does it bloop or swing?
Bloop.
Another question to start asking from this point on.
Do you think those are that's like flames coming out of his hands or could those be
taken off as like wraps and he can tie you up?
I think they're like flames that he can turn on with the snap of a finger.
Like he just sort of activates them before a fight.
That's cool.
All right.
I like the I like the dazzle.
I like the it's showing off.
Yeah, the pageantry.
That's a baby.
I'm cherishing this baby.
My kid is so cute.
I love my kids.
I heard you like my kids.
Yeah, you dams.
Right.
I like my kids.
My kid was adorable.
Do you like my kids?
Yeah.
I like my kids.
I can't even remember how that song goes.
I haven't heard that so long.
Oh my God.
It's a do you like waffles?
Yeah, we like waffles.
Do you like french toast?
Yeah, we like french toast.
Do you like pancakes?
Yeah, we like pancakes.
Dude, dude.
Can't wait to get a mouthful.
Waffles.
Oh my God.
Holy crap.
Passing on the like it.
Would give them waffles, though, as a treat.
Marsh top also would pass,
but give some waffles as a treat.
Maybe pancakes or french toast, whatever they prefer.
I'll give them a little breakfast buffet.
Swampert is in that ready to go position.
Honestly.
Swampert like he's ready to go.
He's got he's got the form.
Bella Hadid.
Homie can get it, you know.
Oh, yeah.
He can get it.
Shape of water.
Oh, I just heard thunder.
My sky is yellow outside.
Oh, maybe we should wrap it up soon.
Oh, yeah.
Do you want to end on?
Do you want to end on actually like
swampert?
I regret I have another.
I have a blue website stream I need to prepare for.
Yeah, we can end on here because it's the perfect smash.
Perfect smash.
Swampert.
And then next time next time we'll get through the 40.
Yeah.
Unless you want to speed run the 40.
Oh, man.
But the commentary is like the best.
I know.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm looking at Puccino like I know what's next.
Now why'd you go on and spoil it for me?
I was going to be surprised.
Because unlike Houndower and Houndoom,
both Puccina and Mighty Anna can get it.
But like that's a conversation for next time.
In the next episode.
And like I'm not wrong.
They both can get it.
They're both hot.
I will never confirm nor deny.
That's okay.
I'll confirm it.
And like they only speak in facts.
They're hot.
Hot dog.
Okay.
On that note, thank you guys for coming to stream.
I hope you guys enjoyed the smash or pass.
Let me find someone to raid.
Do you have any words you want to say?
Trinket, please check out Trinket.
Her stuff is in my description by the way.
Please go to her Twitch channel and follow and subscribe.
Parting words of wisdom.
Always read your terms and conditions.
And never drink orange juice after brushing your teeth.
Yes.
Oh my god.
Thank you for the words of wisdom.
Anytime.
I was going to do something and I already forgot.
It was you're going to look for somebody to raid.
Oh, that's it.
Thank you.
Again, I'm very forgetful.
You are also going to tell Herum your next plan.
My next plans.
Oh, what for the stream?
Yeah, honestly, I don't really know because I've never
Wait, which stream for blue website?
I don't know.
For blue website, I've never used blue website before.
And I saw someone ask if it was going to be pay walled.
I don't think so.
I think I'll keep it free.
And then maybe have some another unique.
I'll bring a sacrament with me.
I'll bring a pink sacrament with me, perhaps.
Because pink is my favorite color.
But let me find someone to raid.
That'll be.
Yeah.
Wait, what?
What did you say?
Oh, maybe I'll get my nails painted pink this weekend.
Oh, I'll match you.
I'll get my nails done and match you.
Okay.
I'm also distracted because it just started pouring outside.
Holy crap.
Um, let's see.
Oh, gosh.
Excuse me.
Rating on YouTube is so hard.
Uh, I'm going to rate.
Oh, uh, Maeve is playing Dark Souls.
Very, uh, apt because I was playing, um, Eldering yesterday.
So go us.
Tell me hello and have a great time, guys.
We'll see you next time.
Emerald launch into Poochina.
Bye.
Can't find my OBS.
Oh, there it is.
There we go.
Bye, harem.
Bye.
Stinky.
Wait a second.
Thank you for the super.
Thank you, Jay reads.
I just want to say you guys are extremely funny and hilarious.
I know you do blah, blah content, but I do like my, my, my sub for that word.
But honestly, these streams from you are my favorite.
You and Trinket have great dynamic and are unhinged.
The best way is your combos.
Please keep it up.
We always keep it real.
We always keep it unhinged.
Thank you.
You have to have friends who can match my freak.
Yeah.
I mean, she, we, she, I can barely match her freak sometimes.
And I'm, I'm the one in the, the, the fun company, the, I'm trying to be say so.
I'm going to say so none in my, you're, you're, you're in the horpo.
I'll say it.
It's so, it's a matter that YouTube transcript is going to pick it up.
I'm going to keep getting limited.
No, it doesn't really matter.
Um, anyways, bye guys.
Bye.